Your brain is two separate brains.
Two halves, each half doing half the work that is to be you.
Each half sees half of what you see and controls half of your movement
The right holds left
The left controls the right.
The hemispheres of your brain are coordinated through a wire of nerves, however
This wire can be cut off, and this has been used for a while in the treatment of epilepsy.
After cutting the wire, people seemed to be the same, although the brain was divided into two parts.
Except that some of them had chosen their clothes in the morning
With the right hand, the left hand comes to object.
In fact, the left hand often objects, from what affected these patients frustrated.
what happens?
To understand this, remember, see the right brain and control one half, while
He sees the left brain and controls the other half.
But only the left brain can speak.
"Hi."
Because the center of speech is located.
While the right brain can not speak
In normal brains, this is not important because each half communicates with the other through the wire.
But, the separated brains can not, so, you can show the word of the right brain, and ask the person:
"What I saw?",
It will respond with nothing.
Because the left brain, which speaks, has not seen anything !.
At the same time, the right brain will use the left hand to select something hidden from the left brain.
This is really weird !.
Ask the person "why did you stick to this thing?" The left brain that speaks will have to
With a reasonable explanation, but completely wrong,.
"I've always wanted to learn how to solve this."
The left brain does not lie. He just does what the brains always do
Creating stories that explain his past actions to himself at present, a behavior that casts doubt on
On the idea of ​​free will (a long story).
Creating reasons to explain his actions is just something
Do the left brain.
It happens in normal, in all normal and healthy humans all the time, and if you think about it closely, you
You know you have done so much.
Now go back to the experiments.
Give the right brain something, and ask the person, "What's in your hand?" He will not be able to answer.
"I do not hold anything."
When asked to draw, the separated brain can draw two separate objects
At one time, with each hand, the way you find the healthy tough.
These experiments on patients separated by their brains are highly confused
Because it really indicates the possibility of a separate silent intelligence ...
Thing...
Stranger lives in the skull.
You can get different answers for the same questions
So, if your brain is broken, who in this case would you be?
From the outside, it is tempting to think that it is the part of the brain that speaks as you are, however
There is something else that hears and answers questions.
Although the right brain can not speak, it understands the faces, unlike the left brain.
If the left brain is you, you will not know your friends and family amidst a crowd.
Divide the brain into two halves leaving two minds in one head, and the mind that speaks
Do not know that there is someone else in the house.
The left brain can describe the situation in it, but nevertheless it will always be surprised
Of the right brain actions and their interpretation.
There is a question to ask here:
Why the right brain is not frightened after its separation, but instead helps the left brain
Answers questions, and listens to left brain stories about what is happening.
- Is this the best horse ... I do not know.
- Time speculation ...
One answer is that brain division does not make the right brain separate from ... intelligence ... consciousness! ... the person!?
It is always so. The fact is that in ordinary people the right brain grows to act as a companion without a choice.
He initially felt his partnership with the left brain but after the evolution of speech to that
Speech becomes increasingly a central point in life, the right brain silently quits until it coordinates with the left brain.
At this moment, in your head, there are two of you watching this video:
One has a "mind at a moment amazed", and the other mind drives the vision to make sure everything is clear.
In divided brains, the right brain does not lose its senses because change is not great for it
May not agree with this, and may now argue about why this can not be possible, just as expected
Of the left brain to do.
Assumptions On the other hand, divided patients show their brains, at least, in the brain there is something separate ...
Something that can be heard, understood and responded, when exposed to certain circumstances
Your brain is not fully yours !.
who are you?
You two.
But we can go deeper. You are so much.
You are a pile of flesh that is your body and that consists of trillions of cells that have their own lives !.
So, when any point becomes a lot one?
What makes a lot of small things you?
Click here to go to our channels and watch the next part.
Hardly, if you hear the channel "Kurtzat" many things miss you.
Kurgaset?
Kurtzgaset?
What do you know Ashlon pronunciation, but they:) - Edit translation: Bushra Al - Gafri.